[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's huge
oh
is the amazing orange river the longest
river in south africa and we came here
where the orange river gives life to the
dry kalahari desert
and we came to camp in this rugged wild
land
to sleep under the stars far away from
civilization and to find the kalahari
gold that is fishing for the amazing
yellow fish
this is by far the best freshwater fish
that you can catch here in south africa
this river here in the northern cape is
my favorite place in the world and i've
been to over 16 different countries
and this time i'm sharing it with my
team
[Music]
[Music]
wow we're finally here
so daniel yo what about your rematch
fishing
because i won with the chino competition
last time this is robert white wait wait
wait wait back up a minute you guys only
won because i wasn't there to be chatted
i want to join in
okay yep we can do it what's the rules
all right guys
there are a few rules
okay all right here are the rules number
one
we get two practice days because we've
never been to this part of the rectifier
before number two you can use any
fishing method bait lures or fly fishing
number three the one who catch the most
fish wins
any size counts smiley sunshine and mute
will help us to film everything and make
sure no one cheats
smiley you're of me newt girl of grumpy
and sunshine you're with wifey number
five the competition starts from sunrise
and ends at sundown
and we will all throw 200 bucks in the
pot and winner takes all okay so you
guys okay with the rules yeah awesome
what are you guys
i'm gonna go practice smiley you're with
me new company club sunshine let's go
okay guys just just so you know this is
marco he's the expert he's gonna help me
win this competition i hope
we're here with umkulu so let's see what
we can catch he says that this guy is
gonna work
this is a cranker crab right we got this
from our sponsor as well solis anglers
corner so let's see what he's going to
bring us yeah should get some good fish
okay
so we are here in richtersvalt in the
northern cape in south africa
and it is absolutely gorgeous here this
part of the orange river is literally
not seen and lost by a lot of people
it's not visited a lot and that's why
it's so so awesome to be here because
you can actually fish without a lot of
people hanging around you without a lot
of noise
you have to come here guys it's
absolutely gorgeous
we've got a nice competition going
myself daniel nikita let's see what's
happening just a quick shout out to
solis thank you for sponsoring this
video you're awesome marco our guide is
amazing full of fishing tips and tricks
i am using
this red lipless lure
so
yeah let's see if we can try and catch
something
and akira is on quickly with the first
fish of the day
[Music]
up
[Music]
oh
time to move on to the next fishing spot
the river rafting is making this trip
even better
[Music]
and i gotta test the water for big fish
every now and then
[Music]
wow looks like grumpy is on with a nice
fish
[Music]
wow it's the first larger
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
fish one
foreign
[Music]
nate
so from the last video where daniel and
i had a competition husband versus wife
[Music]
yeah guys
i've got to redeem myself honestly
i almost caught him with that last
competition but now i need to show him
that i can really catch some awesome
fish
and i need to uh yeah have your ladies
backs
[Music]
oh guys i'm not having any luck with my
lipless lure so i'm gonna go try a
cranker crab let's go put it on
weather is starting to change this might
not be good for fishing
all right guys so catching yellow fish
on lures is very new to me so uh
you can see there in the background
nikita
wifey and then clifton grumpy
they're practicing as well so i'm
standing far away so they don't see what
i'm using
i just went into some deeper water here
so i changed lures to a jig so let's see
marco the fishing expert he helped me
standing right there behind me
so let's see
i'm looking to target a large mouth
yellow fish because they they get quite
big
and they are rare as well beautiful
beautiful fish
plan to move on and get closer to our
camping location which is still a few
kilometers downriver
just a few quick costs to test the water
while the others move on
yo
yes i just threw in and boom it just
took it
yo
yo
wow
man
wow it's still going
ew and smiley is here with me smiley
look at this it's the big one daniel
yeah it's huge
he's just taking a line
yo
i'm using a jig
and the moment i threw it in it just
touched the water and it just took it
yeah
unbelievable
i think uh grumpy and wifey they're
gonna lose this competition
this is why we come here
to the richtersfeld
a little bit difficult now on the boat
[Music]
oh we're gonna go down here
oh man
we need to bring in this fish quick
because there's rabbits
oh
joke
yep
you need to
i'm gonna record you need to go to the
fish
man i'm holding on to the camera with my
teeth while struggling to keep the line
tight so that i don't lose this big fish
okay okay
the line gets stuck on smiley's rod in
front of me
yep
it doesn't want to come
oh man it's going to be beautiful fish
but we're closing in on the rapids
what's going to come with mock
fish doesn't want to come closer and
we're in trouble because this strong
current is taking us closer to the
drop-off again ah it's chaos
smiley's lure someone got hooked on my
glove and i'm struggling to get out
while fighting the fish at the same time
to make matters worse the wind is
picking up and is blowing us closer to
the drop off
wow guys
the rapid is here
we just stopped the boat
the water is strong
i gotta land this fish quick
oh it's a beautiful large fish
look at it
wow
look at this it's huge we're going to go
to the to the side and then we're going
to show you
oh
yo donnie look at that bro
we almost went down today
yeah and all the lines tangled up
yeah
fun experience oh we got the fish
okay let's take it out
he took the jig
oh here we go
this is the guy that worked the jig
yeah
the beauty
piece it's a beauty huh it's a small
mouth but it's huge i'm just turning it
around to bring it out of the least this
is one of the biggest small mouths i've
seen there in a very very long time
that's quite interesting on the
on the orange they've developed these
very very rubbly lips because they feed
in between the rock spot quite
aggressively
[Music]
wow guys it's an amazing smallmouth
yellow fish
yeah
but we're gonna release it so
go home
[Music]
the cameramen and women also had a go at
fishing and then mute hooked onto a
monster largemouth yellow fish and this
is his first yellow fish ever
so
[Music]
this doesn't happen not with your first
fish
what a beautiful
fish
they are super rare and that is also why
we only do cats
here are some of the highlights before
the competition day
[Music]
beautiful
just let him go
[Music]
we also made some special time for some
fun in the sun
[Music]
we're having some fun on the way
jumping off cliffs
[Music]
i'm gonna win
i'm gonna win
grumpy is over there
look how beautiful this place is
no cars no people
no internet
no rat race
just pure
life
oh nikita's uh trying fly fishing and
he's on
oh we got to our new spot and enjoy the
last race of the sun
camping on the riverbed is one of the
highlights of the trip it's not always
the fishing that makes a trip special
it's these unique moments with special
people that you grow close to sitting
next to the fire and sharing memorable
stories
[Music]
later a few fireflies even joined us and
this is what it looks like up close
[Music]
at night marco made dinner and we just
enjoyed every second of the night life
the sound of the river the crickets and
a lonely fox
sleeping under the stars without tents
on stretchers
this is how you camp in the kalari
[Applause]
and with the sunrise of the next day the
competition kicked off
i'm giving grumpy and nikita all my best
and i'm heading out to fish
[Music]
good morning guys the competition is on
so
i'm a little bit early the other guys
are still
packing their stuff so let's see i'm
gonna use this cranker crab
they say
the early bird catches the worm
in this case let's hope the early bird
catches the fish
[Music]
nikita daniel already started fishing
because he needs extra time he knows i'm
going to win
[Music]
the crab wasn't working so i'm quickly
trying the fly rod num thing just to see
if i can get any bites
and already fishing but he's got no luck
but he's testing water for me
and wifey so once he's got fish we know
there's fish here
all right guys so that spot there didn't
work gonna try it right over here in
these rapids
okay guys so daniel has already uh
drifted up river a bit marquis is gonna
place us at separate uh spots today yeah
so let's start fishing
grumpy is on with the first fish
[Music]
no bites yet guys
nothing yet nothing yet let's try one
more time we're gonna move on
we have to work these rapids
let's go downstream a little bit and
throw up stream again
wow guys
grumpy is on looks like he's getting a
fish molly what do you think he's using
i think he's using that that uh crab as
well i think he's also using a crab
ah we're getting behind
oh there goes wifey as well
we're going
i'm going to catch the winner
ah the winner fish
venti
you're disturbing my fish here
yes that happens when you get married
no mercy
[Music]
first fish of the day
you can check over there daniel's not
that thick
okay guys so we just passed grumpy on
the raft and he caught a barber so
currently he's ahead of everyone so um
yeah i'm gonna try my best with a
cranker crab looks like this
okay so i'm on the rapid hopefully we
catch something let's see
[Music]
keeping the line tight so it just goes
above the raffles on the the bottom
where the rocks are
it's stuck
it's stuck
oh she got it
i went from up there to down there all
the way didn't get anything he came the
second cast first first class
yellow fish grabbing his mouth my morale
is back i'm gonna go i'm gonna
i'm usually great when it comes to
fishing so i don't know what's going on
it's like god is testing me
finally my first fish thank you
man
all right
now we just have to get him
where it's supposed to be
just turn it this way
the currently strong so you don't want
to take the fish against the currents
and bring him
yo
this is why we come here
such a little fish but he's strong these
currents
they live in these waters they used to
be strong currents so even if they
little man they put up a fight
thanks man beautiful we're on the board
guys
beautiful
thank you thank you
stunning fish i'm happy
right in its mouth
high five guys
okay so basically with the ninth thing
we're standing just below the rapid and
then you're taking your fly rod
and you're just throwing it gently into
the stream and then keeping your line
tight you're watching as the drifts fall
is it still on yep
it's not a fish it's not in the bag
oh this one's a bit
oh it's also small
this one's feisty
watch out okay
okay and
underneath
when we take off the hook we try and be
as gentle as possible
as to not hurt the fish
[Music]
second one
you want to try a little bit more than
everything
yeah okay let's do it
number three
it's not landed yet yeah
but today's not about sizes but
oh
[Music]
doesn't matter it's oops yeah okay guys
oh guys number
guys
six
the nymphing is working for quantities
we're going to also pick it up
yes
look at that beauty
[Music]
number seven guys
little one whoops okay there it goes
okay so danielle
i'm on my way to number eight
what method are you using
oh you wish to know i do what what then
woman
she's probably using the polyrod
one last cast before i move on to the
next stop
[Music]
so we testing out some new water and uh
marco just showed us just one cost and
uh
the fish took it
the lure is also stuck so marco is going
to get it out unfortunately it will also
chase the other fish away
the only plan is to move up river
no bites so we moved on and suddenly
everyone was falling
sunshine first
then marco
[Laughter]
and then smiley
[Laughter]
grumpy is on with another catfish
clifton yes there's your bauble well
done well done just before lunch i like
a nice big one yeah let's keep them
coming huh thank you shot
i jumped on the action with my own
catfish rod and i'm on with a fish but
so is grumpy again we're on neon grumpy
let's see maybe it's the same one it
probably is but let's see whose hook
it's gonna be
it's gonna be grumpy
it's gonna be mine definitely so grumpy
and captain they've each got a
catfish on the line
i'm just giving them time to catch up to
me a bit so currently i'm standing on
seven i'm not sure about their counts
but i know it's lower than mine um yeah
i've got my catfish line up i'm waiting
yes if it's the same fish then
it's very flexible
i think it's
let's
done
this is probably
the greatest
catfish you'll see
both folks look at this teamwork
yeah wifey this is teamwork huh
we have to join up what does that count
a half inch
[Laughter]
i don't know
oh feeds point five
a fish is a fish huh yeah i've never
seen this before
grumpy you're on again yeah i'm on your
but wifey is on as well look look
[Music]
yeah she's going for eight now yes it's
probably it's probably a guppy
this is a hit so far
we have to do some extreme measures here
this is going to be let's do teamwork
uh it is a smaller bauble but fishes
fish fish is fish it's got scales no it
doesn't necessarily have a bubbles
it's pulling again
i'm going with it and strike
ah man
really
luke
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
guys this is number eight i'm still
leading wow
another fish got away man
god must be testing me
yes
[Music]
catching up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
four big fish
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the wind is too strong my beard is
wow look it's weird yeah
and it's long
ah
daniel
[Music]
[Applause]
and nikita is on with another fish
the wind is pumping
but the fish are biting so that's good
[Music]
yoga
[Music]
[Music]
grumpy
and grumpy is on with another fish
i'm falling far behind
look at it
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
yeah nice
it's a fatty
huh i'm out of another one
hold on fish
guys we're struggling to fish because
the wind is so strong
just look there the mountains
a lot of dust from the wind
[Music]
daniel captain
he should just give up now i'm leaving
it's not over until the fat lady sings
and the sun is down
as if he's gonna catch up
[Applause]
[Music]
finally i'm on with a yellow
[Music]
just lost it
again
i lost another fish
and grumpy is on with another one
[Music]
man
grumpy is on
mine is stuck
but marco is getting it out and grumpy
is slowly moving forward
looks like uh nikita is also stuck there
i'm gonna have to help grumpy the nate
[Music]
well done
how did it take win
nice
enjoy it
fish on for wifey and she's using myra
marku must have given it to her
[Music]
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
okay guys so i caught a very nice small
mouth yellow fish
and that's with daniel's rod because i
was busy changing the lure on my rod
thank you so much daniel you're welcome
three hello
beautiful fish
well dessert
yeah so i've got my personal best
my 600 logie
used a nice
that thing on it
time's running out but i'm not done
right on with another smaller yeah
are they small
but for the competition
wow wow still
still running a little bit
these yellow fish are awesome
man they're so little but so powerful
because they're so used to these
currents i mean look at this
look
i say there are strong fighters
bring him home
[Music]
all right
let's release it
joe getting nervous now
it has got 10
fishes and i've got only six
although mine was bigger
my time is running out sun is always
down
so let's check what's happening
guys i'm giving it my best here even
though i know i won't win
that is how you live life and i'm
enjoying every bit of this i mean just
look at this place
guys we've literally got like half an
hour left of the sun before the
competition ends up got no idea who's in
front of who who's ahead grumpy
captain wifey um but yeah let's see in a
few minutes who's the winner
[Music]
and this is how it ends
wet what happened
it's so slippery it's like smart all
over the garage
it's not a good ending for me
wow all right guys
it's not a good ending for me the sun is
already going down i'm not winning
let's go to grumpy and wifey and uh
let's call it
[Music]
all right guys the competition finished
yeah we just want to say thank you to
all of our sponsors thank you to marco
from cooler adventures it was an amazing
trip yeah you guys enjoyed thank you bye
donkey
and uh the winner who's the wait say it
say it
well done it's good yo alright guys
we'll see in the next video cheers